I don't think Rock Bottom looks like we
like it does in the movies for most of
us most of us Rock Bottom I believe is
that quiet life of desperation it's when
you just pull the car in neutral and you
say this is what this is going to be
this is what my marriage is going to be
this is my granddad's fate he had a
heart attack my dad had high blood
pressure this is the this is the hand
the the deck of cards I was deal and so
I think Rock Bottom for most of us is
giving up this is is is taking her hand
off the gas our foot off the gas and so
yeah my rock bottom
was oh this is just the way this is
going to be you're going to constantly
be chasing and it was that little
glimmer of hope this little glimmer of
an idea that no wait I minut I got a
choice here I can choose something
different and I want something different
for my son I want something different
for my marriage I want something
different for me and that was the
turning point for me